uh welcome and thank you so much for
joining us we're here to talk about AI
for ELA um we have Maddie with us from
Hobart Indiana Sarah and myself are from
KH Academy um so let's just start with a
set of introductions um let's start with
Maddie I'll could get it to awesome hi
everybody my name is Maddie B and I am
the English department chair at hobbert
High School uh we've had a really good
relationship in our district with KH
Academy for a long time and we uh pilot
did the program con Migo last year in a
few of our English classes including
mine I've been teaching English here for
eight years and I teach um a lot of the
early college classes we have here in
hobbert and it's been really cool to use
this program to help with that hello
everyone I'm Sarah Robertson I'm a
senior product manager at KH Academy um
like Aviv and Maddie I started my career
as a middle school Ela and Humanities
teacher at a title one school in Boston
um and then I transitioned into edtech
as the founding head of product at
commonlit.org which is another wonderful
nonprofit resource for ELA teachers if
you don't already use it and yeah today
I'm really excited to talk about kigo
and elay thank you Sarah and I'm aiv
Weiss um I've been at Khan Academy for
about five years but before that I was
an eighth grade ELA teacher and before
that I taught in a Hebrew immersion
school so um I've been working on trying
to get reading and writing to be
something that kids love doing for a
long time and I
I uh transitioned to edtech because I
had this far away sort of sci-fi dream
that something like what we're about to
talk about today could be possible um so
let's let's get right into it um I want
to First tell you before we dive into
specifically uh Ela and what AI is doing
for ELA and what it could can do I just
want to tell you a little bit about how
Khan Academy is approaching AI so
everything that we do has always been
research-based in pedagogy and grounded
in learning science um the same is true
for how we're approaching kigo from how
our lesson plans are designed um to
actually planning the tool so that
learning is built into every single
interaction that students are having
with kigo um we started something called
Con Academy districts a few years ago
with the goal of supporting teachers and
admins so that we're driving deep
learning at scale and so when we talk
about bringing go to the classroom in a
school district we're talking about
supporting administrators teachers
students Al together and we're actually
we take very seriously the fact that we
only allow students to have inclass
access to Kiko in our partner districts
and that's because we take the safety of
of this new environment really seriously
um and also because we we believe that
that ecosystem is really important to
protect and that we have those feedback
loops going from teacher to student
teacher to student and with the support
of admins and instructional coaches um
another way to get student access to
some of the things you'll see today so
if you're a family who wants to get con
go for your own family you can uh allow
your student to work on some of this
stuff at home uh the last thing I want
to say is that um one of the reasons
that the KH Academy team is so
passionate about our our work on kigo is
because we believe that AI can be
offered really ethically to classrooms
um we have a responsibility to help our
students be really good digital citizens
to know how to think critically about
what they're seeing out there in the
world and AI is just another opportunity
for them to practice some of those
really important skills we also think
it's really important to model and lead
the way how to mitigate risks when
dealing with something that is so new
like this so I hope that aners some of
your questions is sort of the context in
which all this is coming down from we we
have um a lot of stuff out there across
our YouTube channel and our blog sort of
showing you how the team is thinking
about it and how schools that we've
piloted the program with are are using
the tool um so this is just a a quick
overview but know that there's a lot
more information out there so here's
what I was hoping we could talk about
today I would love if uh we could hear
from Sarah problems big deep problems
that anyone who's taught in an Ela
classroom before thinks that are are
completely unrealistic to like you would
need magic in order to solve them I
would love if Sarah could talk to us
about the types of problems that at KH
Academy we're really trying to solve now
um show us specifically the sa feedback
tool and then Maddie has some really
amazing examples of how um kigo is being
used to push your students on their
close reading skills um and also Maddie
is the department head for ELA and she's
been able to create some really amazing
plans um using kigo and then we'll talk
about the future state of of AI for ELA
and we'll close out with a coupon code
that everyone here can use to
immediately try cono for yourself if you
haven't yet done so um so uh let's talk
about how kigo is capable right the
second to help students and and teachers
in supporting student writing so I'm
going to kick it to Sarah all right when
I taught seventh grade reading many
years ago
um most of my students were behind grade
level I think that is unfortunately
pretty common and I knew that research
showed that in order to improve my
students writing skills my students of
course needed direct instruction and
modeling from me um they also needed to
be doing a lot of writing ideally they
should be writing almost every day and I
also knew that writing Alone um is not
enough to help students improve
obviously they need feedback and in
order for that feedback to be effective
it needed to be focused and specific it
needed to be actionable um something
that they could immediately improve upon
it needed to be aligned to clear
objectives that I set and it needed to
be delivered often and in a timely
manner but the reality and I'm sure this
is probably true for most of you is that
I had about a 100 students and if I were
to assign say one essay a week I think
that's being pretty aspirational that's
at least 30 assignments per school year
which equals 3,000 student essays to
provide feedback on and that's assuming
that I'm only providing feedback on one
of the students drafts like their first
draft and then not looking at the final
draft or just evaluating their final
draft and not giving them an opportunity
to revise so if I limited myself then to
10 minutes per essay to provide
personalized detailed feedback on every
student's draft
can anybody guess how many hours I'd
spend per school year giving feedback
given this this is an Ela crowd I I bet
you all have to pull out your
calculators um it's 500 hours 500 hours
in a school year it is just not possible
um especially when in most cases
teachers are not just responsible for
teaching writing but also reading or you
know other Humanity subjects so what
typically happens typically we assign
fewer essays sometimes just a handful a
year um when we do assign essays
students have to wait days or even weeks
for us to finish providing feedback or
we just provide way less detailed
feedback maybe we just circle some
things on a rubric um or we only
evaluate the final draft or we rely a
little too much on the sometimes
unreliable uh peer feedback approach or
we work completely unsustainable hours
and we're trying to do the right thing
but ultimately we get get burnt out so
when KH Academy set out about a year ago
to start thinking about ways that we
might better support ELA teachers it was
right around the same time that chaty PT
was released and we pretty quickly
recognized the potential for AI to help
teachers in this area specifically and
we also recognized the problems that
writing teachers faced um
uniquely in this age of AI um now that
AI is making it easier than ever for
students to take the easy way out I
think you all know what I'm talking
about um and this is something that we
really made a concerted effort and and a
decision to to start pursuing and to
start
exploring so I am going to demo for you
um the first writing feature on Con
Academy it's called the kigo academic
essay feedback activity and the purpose
of this activity specifically is to
allow your students to get immediate
specific highquality feedback on their
writing and support with revising their
essay at their own pace the goal is for
students to get more feedback to get
more practice writing while still
allowing you to focus on the many many
important things that you do like
targeting key skills working one to one
working in small groups developing real
human relationships with students and
note also that this tool doesn't yet
support students with planning and
drafting an essay but that will be
coming soon so stay tuned at the end for
a sneak peek um of some upcoming
features for next school year so I'm
going to switch now to a different
tab all right do you all see the Con
Academy page now can I get a thumbs up
from aiv or mateline yes okay great that
worked easier than I was
expecting wonderful okay so this is the
academic sa feedback activity on KH
Academy and to get here students will
just go to their AI activities page this
is sort of the kigo homepage um and the
activity is right here on the menu
underneath right give feedback on my
academic essay and to start students
just paste in their initial draft uh the
maximum word count right now this is
probably going to increase fairly soon
but right now it's 1750 words you can
see that this pretty basic five
paragraph essay here is 588 words so I'm
well within that
limit um and I'm using a sample essay on
Romeo and
Juliet and currently the activity works
best for middle and high school grades
um it can work for lower level grades
but the feedback may be a little bit
Advanced um it also works best for
persuasive or argumentative essay essays
explanatory or expository essays and
literary analysis essays um students
should also paste in the essay prompt so
that kigo is aware of what the actual
assignment is and can check to make sure
that the essay is aligned to that and is
meeting the requirements that the
teacher sets so I'm going to click
submit for
review now the AI is analyzing the essay
and generating feedback in five main
areas Each of which are content experts
in AI promp Engineers have spent more
than six months perfecting against
stringent quality standards I am talking
like the most intense um rubric like
checking so many thousands of drafts to
make sure that things that we're putting
in front of students are accurate are
fair are ethical and that they are you
know grade level appropriate so we feel
really good about the quality of this
feedback um the current five areas that
kigo gives feedback on are introduction
and this includes things like the lead
or the hook of the of the introduction
thesis the overall alignment of the
essay in general to The Prompt um
evidence and reasoning structure and
organization conclusion style tone
language and
vocabulary and research tells us that
highlighting one feedback area at a time
for students helps them focus on
improving one set of writing skills
versus being completely overwhelmed by a
paper that's been heavily marked up for
a whole variety of issues so students
can filter by specific feedback area
note that while we're analyzing the
essay for feedback just like other kigo
activities we're also moderating the
essay for safety so teachers parents
admins can see when students use the
activity what their first draft looked
like they can see the feedback that kigo
gave them um they can see any chats the
student had with kigo about the feedback
they can see the latest essay draft and
if anything is flagged for moderation by
our moderation checks then teachers
parents admins they all get a
notification email um once K goes done
generating you can see that it's
finished here um you'll notice that
students get a mix of both positive
feedback and critical feedback and some
feedback is at the whole essay level um
other feedback can be about a specific
section of the text um or even specific
sentences and so kigo will highlight the
pieces of the text the feedback is about
so that the student can hone in on that
all right so let's dig in here um one
thing that I think makes this activity
particularly powerful is excuse me is
that um this is not just a feedback tool
it's really a revision tool um the
student can make revisions on the spot
and get immediate help and feedback to
act on each suggestion so so I'm going
to pick a piece of feedback here and I'm
going to give that a try Okay so this is
about my thesis statement here again
this is an essay on Romeo and juliad and
which character is most responsible for
the tragedy the students thesis just
says however frier Lawrence is the most
responsible the feedback is telling the
student to make their thesis statement
more specific um it's telling me to
explain briefly why or how he is the
most responsible so it's not telling me
exactly how to change it it's just
telling me
a general way that I might improve upon
it and one of the things that students
can do is they can ask kigo to give them
an example and again this is not like
other AI tools that might actually
provide a um suggested revision for the
student to just accept and beyond their
merry way it will give an example from a
different essay so in this case kigo is
giving an example for an essay about
fast food and it says instead of a
thesis like fast food food is the most
responsible for health problems it says
fast food significantly contributes to
health problems due to reasons X Y and Z
so now as a student I have a model that
I can use to improve my thesis so if a
student and I'm being quick here for the
demo purposes but let's say I want to
revise my thesis based on this model um
I'm going to past some examples here
frier Lawrence is most responsible due
to his role as a trusted adviser
involvement in their secret marriage and
his unfortunate planning so I can now
ask kigo is that
better and if I left something out or if
my language is unclear kigo will tell me
in this case looks acceptable I'm going
to mark this as result and go back to
the rest of my feedback um
and now that I uh can resolve this I can
move on to another piece of feedback um
if I'm going to show another example of
a case where a student might get help
revising so um similar to just general
feedback on on making sure that the
student is sort of checking the general
boxes of basic essay structure um it can
also support students on things like
style and tone so in this particular
essay uh the student is using some
vocabulary um in some language that's
like a little un formal for a 10th grade
academic essay so an example that kigo
points out here is that the sentence
says this decision made the secrecy
around their relationship even worse and
kigo is pointing out that there's
another way that you could write this to
make it more specific or can make it
kind of more academic sounding so I can
ask kigo to give me an example or I can
ask it to explain the suggestion too
let's say it gives feedback that is a
little too vague for the student they
need some more specific
um so in this case it's telling the
student that they could explain how
specifically uh frier Lawrence's
decisions uh uh made the secrecy worse
uh did make it harder for Ry and juliia
to communicate Etc it's giving the
student ways that they can improve
without giving them the exact directions
for how to do it and the student can
have a whole back and forth conversation
with kigo about this feedback it can ask
uh kigo for um word example so it can it
can act as a thesaurus or a dictionary
but it won't give exact sentences for
the student to write so let's say I
wanted to think of another word to
describe like to make something worse I
could say um what's a more academic way
of
saying make
something
worse
and it's giving me the word exacerbate
the situation or intensify the problem
this is a really wonderful tool to teach
students new vocabulary words and give
them um examples of of ways to phrase
things that might be you know more grade
level appropriate so I could make those
revisions and again Ask kigo to evaluate
my new
revisions and that is the gist of it I
know we're short on time so um to recap
some things that make this activity
different from some other AI writing
tools out there is that the focus is on
high quality feedback um the feedback is
specific it's immediately actionable the
student can get revised uh follow-up
feedback right away it the feedbacks
across a range of Dimensions the user
experience actually supports the student
through the revision process without
ever doing the writing for them um and
that's it for the demo and I think I'm
passing it off to Maddie great thank you
I've seen this tool in action that Sarah
just showed with my own students um I
had a few of them try it as soon as the
feature went live I got so excited
personally as a teacher and I'm seeing a
bunch of teachers in the Q&A right now
saying the same kinds of things like oh
my gosh it's unbelievable that it can do
this much um the amount of feedback they
were able to get in a timely fashion it
really did impact the quality of their
drafts in a way that I as an educator in
the classroom really appreciate um it's
been amazing to see iGo develop even
over the past six months from the user
side uh because we piloted back in the
spring and uh having it now in January
it's absolutely remarkable how it's
changed um I know some people also
arrived a little late and might not have
heard of VI say that there will be
answers that will be released in a blog
post you said right for some of the
questions they're putting in the chat um
but one of the ones that had been asked
um for me was what grade levels I use
kigo with so I will tell you right now
in my district I use it with nth graders
11th graders and 12th graders and I also
use it as a department chair for uh
curricular planning to kind of
streamline that process and that's more
of what I'm going to speak to today so
here in hobbert uh we live right uh
underneath Lake Michigan uh and I I say
that because it's actually super timely
that this webinar is happening today
because it's one of the first first days
I've been back in school this entire
month due to just weather absolutely
wild weather patterns I've heard all
over the country it's been kind of that
way and um I have to tell you that
conmigo has made my e-learning
experience with my students it's so much
more effective and I do have some
examples that in my slides for today
that are from actual students who used
kigo to help them in e-learning so if
you can go ahead and hit the next slide
so
the and and I know the text is kind of
small I apologize but so for these
screenshots that we have here these are
from my actual students one handy
feature about conmigo is uh you always
have access to your students chat log so
I asked my students on the e-learning
day my specifically my dual credit
seniors who are in an American lit class
to chat with conmigo about a little bit
more of a niche story uh we were looking
at AMR beer at the time and we were
looking at An Occurrence at Owl Creek
brid Bridge in chaga and those are some
pieces that you know they're they're not
exactly Romeo and Juliet or Edgar Allen
Poe right not everybody has exposure to
Ambrose beerus and their High School
experience I know I had not in my own um
what I was so astounded by was how
indepth kigo was able to go in engaging
with my students I had asked them to
chat with k go kind of seminar style
about any kinds of questions they might
have had about the reading things they
didn't understand about the story right
or anything that they um they wanted to
talk about deeper that we couldn't do
because we weren't together in class you
know it's a seminar style College
literature class so we move on pretty
quick um and I really wanted to make
sure they didn't lose out on that depth
so they were still able to have that
conversation with kigo so this first
that we have here is actually the purple
is my student um and he is one of the
brightest ones in the class and the top
15 of his graduating class and he chose
to use his time with K Migo just kind of
chatting about this deeper level of the
text so uh you know he talks about how
um you know he was picturing how the
symbolism really you know related to the
overall message of the story um relating
to the idea that beer might want the
reader to know War isn't what you think
until you've experienced it right and
and talking about how the symbol
connected to that message kigo was able
to respond to him um as effectively as
another student in the class might have
and I actually have a quote from that
student where he had said later on that
it really enhanced his ability to
understand that reading he said it
allowed me to give to get feedback on
some of the analogies I had picked up on
and it made me feel really prepared to
talk about the work in front of someone
else and fleshed out my ideas in a
helpful Manner and it even asked him in
various sections oh do you have a quote
that'll support your understanding of
this um and so it was it was really
remarkable to read over his chat log
with kigo and how you know effectively
it was able to meet his needs even as a
college level reader uh in a more Niche
text it was able to engage kind of in
depth here um and you can see in the
chat here that it was kind of
reinforcing first what he said affirming
what he had said and then asking him to
dig a Little Deeper um on the next slide
after this one of if you could switch it
this is one of my students who I would
say uh she's she's more of an average
level performer in the course right uh
reading is not always her strong suit so
she was having a hard time with the
background information related to the
story what was the purpose of the
railroads that were going over the
kigo actually is able to give her that
historical context that even the Norton
anthology of American literature had not
given to my student so you know on the
one hand we can see a student here who
was looking to really Elevate his
understanding on the other were looking
at someone who needed the the gaps kind
of bridged there and it was able to meet
both of their needs even though I wasn't
with them in person um overall their
experience using that program outside of
the class classroom they were very happy
with it um these are the same students
who had piloted the program the year
before but they did so in a writing
class so this was really one of their
first times engaging with it in in
reading and and they were thrilled they
went oh my gosh I would absolutely do
this again it did exactly what you would
have done Miss bch they it really
encouraged me so this is just a a real
world example of how it worked for them
um and then now I wanted to kind of
pivot a little bit and speak to to um
how I'm using it as an educator kind of
outside of um in my classroom that I do
many lessons with cono like that one
pretty regularly again especially during
e-learning but I will tell you that the
thing that really pushed me over the
edge from being a teacher that was more
nervous about AI than excited about
embracing it was through seeing all of
the ways that it could help streamline
that behind the scenes were work as a
teacher um I don't have any slides on it
today but one thing that I wanted to
note is there is a tool in cono where
you can have rubrics created for you um
based on your own assessments um my
school district we were working on
really building some cohesive language
in our rubrics and cohesive formatting
um we do about 10 units per year in our
ninth and 10th grade
classes I think since there's so many
English teachers the webinar today
there's like almost 600 people here I
know you would know exactly what I'm
talking about when I say English
teachers take a long time to write a
good rubric right we care so much about
finding the perfect way to phrase those
differences between something that is
excellent versus uh you know meeting a
standard above standard meeting standard
approaching a standard and having those
little descriptors for each performance
level um rubrics used to take me up to
an hour to make on my own and we were
able to get 10 rubrics made in a half
day in my district we took a curriculum
mapping day we had our performance task
ready we had K go open and we made all
of those rubrics and they're exceptional
we made them in a half day another thing
that we used kigo for this summer was
rebuilding our grammar program in our
district um we were unhappy with um a
lot of the grammar resources that are
out there outside of you know programs
such as Khan Academy uh we were looking
into something that really we could make
our own right tailor to our students
we're K12 District how could we build
something that would meet our kids'
needs so we spent the summer working uh
in a team there were three of us and we
met three times in person where we went
through grades 6 through 12 and
identified where according to the
Indiana State Standards kids should be
meeting certain benchmarks in terms of
grammar um which fun fact in Most states
our kids are supposed to have mastered
all of grammar by the start of 11th
grade and I'm sure many of us would be
thinking to ourselves my my students
aren't there I know mine aren't there
right so we wanted to build something
that was vertically
articulated 6 through 10 and that's
pretty ambitious to in one summer so we
first brainstormed here you can see on
this slide when certain skills would get
covered so we focused on three per mini
unit in a particular quarter you can hit
the next
slide from there we went to cono and
said okay so if we want to draft content
for these mini units for grammar we're
going to need some topics so here's some
overall categories can you help us bring
brainstorm some fun little subcategories
we can touch on here so like interesting
careers that students wouldn't know a
lot about historical figures that have
amazing backstories um food with weird
backstories um kigo taught us about all
kinds of historical events we knew
nothing about uh just so we would be
able to have non-fiction based quizzes
for grammar that were engaging things
that they would actually you know read
and have a good time with and then you
can hit next
slide this is really where kigo then
came into play aside from generating the
ideas with us we then asked for the
program to draft the base sentences for
the daily sentence practice our students
would do during the week as well as the
paragraph-based quiz that they would
complete at the end so we added the
errors ourselves afterward but you know
really thinking this through for a
second the hardest part in my opinion of
making any grammar resource is coming up
with enough non-fiction content off the
top of our heads where we're not
plagiarizing somebody else uh that we
could then build our own needs into
right kigo was able to do that drafting
phase for us so we could really
authentically focus on embedding what we
needed so I was able to prompt the
program in the uh create a lesson
feature and just say hey I'm looking to
make a grammar quiz
uh covering you know a few Concepts here
could you give me a paragraph suited for
a nth grader that is about the great emu
war and it do it did magically I had
this paragraph ready to go and all I had
to do was add the errors in that I would
have my students correct so on the next
slide you can see what those sentences
then end up looking like in that
particular unit they have 10 sentences
per uh little section of the quarter and
so the errors are already embedded kigo
did the initial draft I cleaned it up
from there and then on the next slide
you have what that final quiz would look
like so
again I didn't have to do the initial
draft I was able to just focus on adding
in what my kids needed it really
expedited my own planning process uh I
did one quarter of these grammar re
resources in four hours over winter
break that's an entire quarter of
resources that's 10 sentences per little
mini unit plus an entire paragraph quiz
in four hours and that's unheard of for
me the amount of time I am able to save
and then guarantee vertical articulation
in my district from 6 through 10 that's
phenomenal right our kids will be able
to build with these resources and I've
had my my own students when they are
having trouble let's say with
parallelism I have them ask kigo for
extra practice it will generate practice
problems for them so if these exercises
that I'm giving in class are not enough
for them to be able to bridge their own
learning gaps they can use the program
outside of school to be able to get that
atome tutor that they need without
having to pay for it so those are just a
few of the ways that I've used Con in my
own classroom like I said what sold me
more than anything was how it's not only
able to be there to be a tutor for my
kids which is huge and you
know that that is phenomenal for them
it's but it's also you know frankly just
based on what Sarah was talking about
earlier it's been huge on cutting down
the number of hours that I needed to
devote to the planning part of my job
because then I can take that energy and
that time and devote it more more so to
helping my students as humans and as
people and that's why we sign on for
this profession right is not because
we're so passionate about spending hours
writing grammar we're grammar practice
we're we're more passionate about
helping kids and I can go back to that
part of my job that I love so I hope
this is helpful um I think those are the
ends of my slides of you so I'll pass it
back over to you thank you so much
Maddie and I'm I'm sure what everyone is
appreciating uh in hearing you speak is
that you know there's this uh there's
this tendency to think about AI as a
thing that just gets us out of something
or saves us time because we don't have
to do the thing but I think it both in
in your student examples and in your own
planning work it's so clear that it's a
really strategic application of the AI
to help you do something even better um
than you could have done without it so I
really appreciate the examples you
shared um I want to turn it back to
Sarah in our last few minutes to talk to
us all about what the future of AI for
for ELA looks like um Sarah we would
love to hear your predictions things
you're excited about and then anything
you could tell us about um what your
team is working on building for teachers
and
students thank you aiv and thank you
Maddie I had the privilege of actually
visiting Maddie's classroom a couple of
weeks ago and it was just as magical as
you might expect based on all of those
wonderful examples that she shared so
thank you Maddie for for joining this um
so earlier I talked a lot about feedback
and revision um but I speak to a lot of
ELA teachers as part of my job and there
are two things that I know are are top
of mind when it comes to writing for
many ELA teachers right now one of those
is empowering students to just get
started on an essay to begin with you
know I shared the writing feedback tool
with some teachers recently and they
were like this is really awesome but
like I have a hard enough time just
getting a first draft out of my students
um and the second is the very real
problem that I think has been mentioned
in the Q&A section multiple times
already of AI plagiarism and cheating
and I can't give too much of a preview
because we are still a few months away
from launching this but I'm excited to
share that in the next school year kigo
will be able to support students through
the entire essay drafting process from
breaking down and understanding an essay
prompt to brainstorming the students
response to that essay to outlining the
essay to drafting the essay and then of
course feedback and revision um we're
calling this kigo writing coach
currently and not only will this tool
support students from the very beginning
of their writing process but it will
also be able to provide you as their
teachers with both highlevel insights on
students writing skills
and detailed documentation about each
student's writing process from start to
finish including potential originality
Flags is what I think we're we're
calling them at the moment so imagine
for a moment a report that tells you
that your students struggled most with
outlining or your students struggled
most with integrating
evidence and that you might want to look
closely at the documentation for this
specific students assignment because
they pasted a large block of texts from
a mysterious Source or because the draft
that appeared didn't align to the
outline that the student worked on with
kigo when we're able to kind of document
that entire writing process it will be a
lot easier to point to moments where it
seemed like the student didn't do this
by thems since you know we are having
the student walk with kigo through this
whole process and the goal here is to
focus as much on the process of writing
as the product of writing because we
know that so many of the academic
benefits of writing in general come from
the experience of thinking critically
and Drafting and making mistakes and
rewriting and reorganizing and
brainstorming all these pieces of the
writing process are really what develop
such critical skills in our students so
stay tuned for writing coach um and I
don't want to also leave out reading
because reading is very near and dear to
my heart I think some of the examples
Maddie shared are wonderful application
of kigo for for reading teachers right
now but we also have some exciting other
reading features that we're currently
exploring and experimenting with and um
hope to have something for reading soon
um for the next school year so stay
tuned for that as well and as always the
product team at KH Academy is very eager
to hear your your thoughts your feedback
so um definitely Reach Out Feel Free
like aiv said to add questions in the
Q&A currently and we'll we'll get back
to you um and I'm just really excited
for you all to be here thank you all for
joining this learning session to try out
con Migo's essay feedback feature for
yourself or with your students and to
see more of how kigo is already working
in classrooms click the links you see
here and don't forget to subscribe to KH
Academy for the latest updates and for
more free world-class educational
content happy
learning